so um welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rues as usual
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk if you have immediate questions
you are welcome to unmute and ask or
otherwise please use the chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in the Q&A session at the
end second today's seminars is open to
external audience so no classified
discussion is allowed finally the talk
will be recorded and upload to our
YouTube channel now let me introduce our
speaker it is an honor to host Analisa
quen who is the professor and the
associate chair in the Department of
Mathematics at the University of Houston
she earned her Bachelor and master
degrees in the aerospace engineering at
Poly Technical deino in 2005 and
received a PhD in Applied Mathematics
from epfl in 2009 her interest are in
the general area of computational
partial differential equations and more
specifically in computational fluid
mechanics with various applications in
medicine biomedical engineering and osic
science she is the recipient of the 2021
to 2022 William andlower harlet
Foundation Fellowship from the Harvard
redcliff Institute she is serving as the
associate editor of the S journal on
scientific Computing and is the founding
editor of advances of computational
Science and and Engineering today she
will talk about reducing the cost of
ocean modeling with a data driven ROM
and Lees please enjoy the wonderful talk
now without further Ado let me hand it
over to
analysa thank you very much Tony for the
uh kind introduction and for the
invitation uh to give this talk in this
uh webinar series it is a great pleasure
for me to give this talk today uh and uh
good morning
everyone uh Tony said I'll talk about
using reduced order modeling and large
Ed simulation to reduce the
computational cost of uh ocean modeling
this is Joint work with Lander basabi
who is a graduate student at University
of Houston mikelo and joh Luigi Roa from
cisa in
Italy let me start by telling you why uh
one would be interested in reducing the
computational cost of ocean modeling
well there are several reasons for that
the first is that if we are interested
in simulating the whole Ocean or even
parts of the ocean we're typically
looking at large computational
domains uh in addition we have a
requirement on the mesh size that we
need to use for the simulations for the
moment I'm just right in here that the
mesh size has to be smaller than uh a
given Quant quantity and I'll specify
that later uh the point that I'm trying
to make here is just is that not only we
have large computational domains we have
also a um requirement on the mesh size
uh that is typically rather stringent so
we need high resolution across uh large
domains and then uh the last Point uh is
that we are typically interested in
longtime intervals
the um the picture that I show uh that I
put here uh on the slide is showing a
phytoplankton as a tracer of a an ocean
G subtropical Jers are sustained
currents spinning thousands of
kilometers across the Pacific and
Atlantic Ocean uh and I am mentioning
them because we will see these gers in
the simulation that I will show later
but also because so uh gers are hostile
environments with nutrients that are in
short supply nonetheless as you can see
in this picture that is a courtesy of
NASA uh phytoplankton lives there and
how that is possible for a phytop
plantant to live within uh a g has been
a mystery for a long time and it's just
about a few years ago that it was found
that the a phytop growth uh happens
thanks to a layer of water below the
ocean surface that allows nutrients to
cycle back to the surface and so I
wanted to mention this too because the
model that I will use for the ocean
simulation includes
stratification so layers uh within the
ocean all right so let me tell you what
we are doing to reduce uh the
computational cost of these otherwise
expensive computationally expensive
simulations first we consider a
simplified PD model and I will discuss
that
first then we use a predictive
datadriven reduce order
model uh which we will see drastically
reduce the computational time uh however
still for the
reduced order modeling we need training
data that come from computationally
expensive simulations so after
introducing the ROM I will uh talk about
an efficient large IDE simulation model
uh so that we can reduce the
computational cost for the training data
uh there is a fourth um work that I
wanted to mention uh although I'm not
talking about today which is the um we
are uh in the process of using
randomized pod for parametric studies so
this uh um the model that we use
features several parameters so one might
be interested in the
parameters varying in a certain range
and so while today I only talk about
time as a parameter we can extend uh the
ROM that I talk about today to include
physical parameters and we contain the
computational cost for that by using
randomized pod but again this is just
work in progress I wanted to mention it
but I'm not talking about it
today let me start with the model and as
I said is a simplified model it uh comes
from the Quasi geostrophic equations
which are one of the most commonly used
models for Mid latitude wind driven
ocean
Dynamics the equations come from the
incompressible navi Stokes equations
under some simplifying
assumptions the first of these
simplifying assumptions is that the
depth is much smaller than the
meridional length in an ocean and um
that is true in the sense that in an O
the ocean is wide uh thousands of
kilometers of square kilometers but the
depth is only up to 11 kilometers so if
uh we take this into account we can go
from the incompressible nav stes
equations to the shallow water
equation so then uh we further simplify
the shallow water equations by
considering that we are near hydrostatic
and geostrophic
balance and one important assumption for
the quas geostrophic equations is the
so-called beta plane
approximation um which amounts to a
approximating the Earth so a sphere with
a tangent plane so you see in uh the
figure here this is again courtesy of
NASA you um see uh ocean the formation
of ocean gers uh in the Atlantic so you
see Florida here and the uh Us East
Coast uh let's say that you're
interested in uh simulations near the uh
New England so you would consider it uh
a domain in the region of interest uh
you you uh the note as y equal to Z the
center of your region of interest and
there you're approximating the Earth
with its tangent
plane so this is the Quasi geostrophic
equations and they assume that the ocean
is one layer at constant density and
temperature and depth which can be a
crude approximation so the uh extension
that we consider is the two layer quasi
geostrophic equations and it's an
extension that attempts to capture
stratification so now we have two layers
U again at constant uh density
temperature and uh depth and um that
they are on the one hand driven by the
ocean we were saying this is a model uh
uh for wind driven ocean Dynamics and
then in contact with the bottom of the
ocean for the bottom layer so I will be
talking about ROM and Lees for this
model the two layer qu geostrophic
equations of course you can add layers
to it so add stratification go over just
two
layers let me show you what the model
looks like in its non-dimensional form
so we have uh four equations here the
top two describe the Dynamics of the top
layer and the bottom two for the bottom
layer uh so in you see the for a forcing
term for the top layer that comes from
the wind it's a wind driven Dynamics and
instead in the bottom layer you see this
term here with a um that it represents
friction with the bottom of the ocean
the variables in this uh coupled problem
are q1 and Q2 which are the potential
vortic vorticities for layer one top
layer and Layer Two bottom layer and uh
s which is the stream function so we
have uh s 1 and S 2 and um you see that
uh in the uh for the uh top layer the
equations are Written In terms of
potential vorticity for the top layer
stream function for the top layer but
you also have the stream function for
the bottom layer so the terms that you
see here are coupling the Dynamics of
the top layer with the Dynamics of the
bottom layer uh and uh similarly you
have similar terms uh in the bottom
layer as I was saying these are the
equations once you have made them
non-dimensional and So You observe the
uh some well-known uh non-dimensional
numbers the first one that is probably
the uh a better known is the rainolds
number that you see here at the
denominator uh as you know the rolds
number is the ratio of inertial force to
viscus force and then there are other
two non-dimensional numbers the rosby
number which is perhaps less known and
that gives you uh an indication of the
ratio of the inertial inertial force to
the coroli force and uh and you you have
it
here and the third non-dimensional
number is the fruit number uh that gives
you the uh ratio of flow inertia to
external force fields which in this case
is
gravity and uh you see it in all four
equations as I was saying earlier if you
wish
to run a simulation of uh with this
model uh you need to be careful uh uh
with uh the resolution in uh your mesh
because you need to be able to resolve
the so-called Mo scale that is the scale
that it's telling that your mesh needs
to be able to resolve and that depends
on l l is just a characteristic size for
your domain and then it depends on the
ratio of rosby number to rainolds number
so you see that the cases that are
challenging are for large rainolds and
small
rosby one uh note that I want to make
here is that the arals number is
typically computed with the Edie
viscosity not the actual viscosity of
water viscosity of water in the metric
system would be of the order of 10 to
the -6 so it will give you very large
rainho number and so it would force you
to use very fine computational meshes so
what is typically done is that that the
value of the viscosity is artificially
increased uh to be able to use a mesh
that is much coarser we can look at this
as really the crudest kind of larg
simulation right where you introduce in
your system a an artificial viscosity
which is constant
and that is done so that again we can
cson the mesh and so we are able to run
a simulation with the uh Computing
facilities that are
disposal uh and the in the literature
the rainolds number with this artificial
value for the viscosity ranges between
few thousand to few hundred again
depending on the Computing facilities
that people
have let me show you some uh a sample of
uh the solution that you get for a um an
extension of a standard test the Double
J Test uh this is used widely used in
the case of the single layer quas
geostrophic equation and we've extended
it to the two layer
case um and we have rosby which is 10 to
the -3 and rainold which is
450 for uh for the mesh to result the
mon scale with these uh values uh we
need uh we need it to be 256 by 5 12 and
we're interested in running the
simulation uh for 100 time units uh with
a uh standard uh uh Computing server
that takes about 8 days and 5 hours uh
so even with the addition of this
artificial viscosity it's still Sim um a
computationally intensive
simulation and what I'm showing you here
is the uh potential vorticity in layer
one in two subsequent uh for two
subsequent time units 2021 and the
potential vorticity in Layer Two and uh
the point that I want to make here is
that you see that there is um strong
convection dominance in this problem and
that is why
after I introduce the reduce order model
I'm going to talk about adding to this
Ed uh crude Eddie viscosity model an
additional large Eddie model to be able
to reduce the computational
time now before I tell you what we have
done for the two layer quas geostrophic
equation I want to tell you what has
been done in the literature and uh to be
able to do that I just want to remind
you
uh the difference between Galler ROM so
sorder models that use gallin projection
versus data driven WR although I'm sure
that you uh you are all aware of this
just a uh brief reminder so we have a
genetic problem that depends on time and
uh red uh a um standard reduce order
model uh uses a uh two-phase procedure
in the first phase
called offline what you do is that you
generate snapshots so you sample your
solution at certain times with those
snapshots you construct a reduced basis
and here I am saying that the number of
bases you uh should be of the order of
10 and in doing that I am
prioritizing computational savings so I
want to ensure that I have indeed a
reduced basis so that I can have a
method that is computationally
efficient uh once I have the reduced
bases I can approximate my variable U as
a linear combination of the basis
functions that I just found and um
coefficients that I still need to find
uh in a uh gallan ROM I would take this
approximation and plug it into uh my
problem so that I can construct the ROM
operators here I'm calling a uh The
Matrix that you get when uh you uh
Associated to the linear operators in
your problem and B The Matrix that is
associated with the nonlinear operators
so that is what you do offline once and
for all and then on online you simply
run your ROM which tells you how the um
the uh a which is the vector collecting
all the coefficients that you have here
evolves over time
time um all right in the case of a data
driven ROM the first three steps in the
offline procedure are the same the
difference is that now I want to be
blind to the underlying uh physical
problem and so I'm not going to plug the
ROM approximation into my uh set of into
my uh problem physical problem I just
want to train a model with the values of
a the vector of the uh coefficients for
the reduced bis functions for the
snapshots and then online what I do is
that I learn the evolution of a from
applying the train
model one point that I want to make
before telling you what is in the
literature is um about how uh the uh IG
values for the uh quasi geostrophic
equations
Decay because one of the techniques that
is widely used to construct the Rong
basis is uh pod so proper orthogonal
decomposition and what that does is it h
gives you the number of modes that are
ranked with based on the uh their igen
values from largest to smallest and so
uh in this slide I am plotting the IG
value DK for the uh quasi geostrophic
equation and that is in blue against
other well-known uh convection dominated
problems like the flow past the cylinder
uh which I believe in this case is a th
for rolds at 1,000 and the um 3D
turbulent Channel flow for rainolds that
is around
13,000 so here you see the dec Theon
value dek for the um flow past the
cylinder um which is slow
but it's not too slow you could still
retain of the order of 10 modes and have
a reasonably uh accurate uh ROM but you
see that in the case of the Quasi
geostrophic equations the EG value Decay
is extremely small so if you
prioritize um uh computational
efficiency as we said earlier so you
just want to retain order of 10 modes
that is going to give you a um
simulation that
if that is going to give you a ROM
approximation that is not accurate
because the
modes that you are desing are very much
relevant to the Dynamics of the
system so with that uh this is a summary
of recent papers on ROMs for qge
models uh everything not
everything uh it's mostly related to the
single single layer
qg and uh there is uh uh gallin ROMs
using pod to generate the B is uh the
reduced bases that use Lees so large ID
simulation inspired closure models or
data driven closure models these models
are needed needed so that you can bring
bring back into your real the effect of
the modes that you are discarding but
that are relevant to the Dynamics of the
system um there is hybrid uh a uh hybrid
gallin projection data driven R proposed
in
2019 and in there what they're doing is
they're taking a convex combination of a
solution given by a Goring from and a
solution given by a data dream ROM uh
using neural networks to learn the
evolution of the modal
coefficients uh finally uh and more
recently uh data driven ROM using pod in
combination with DMD or lstm so it
seemed to us that the combination of pod
and lstm was the most promising to
extend to the two layers qu geotropic
equation and so that's what we
did all that we could find on the two
layer quasi geostrophic equations is uh
a uh paper that dates back to 2016 on
expansion of the baroc clinic barotropic
components of the two two layer
qg so this is what we
do uh for
uh for the
Pod uh so we perform pod not on the
potential icity and the stream uh
function but on the their fluctuations
with respect to the time average over
the training interval so what we're
doing is we are running the um the
simulation for half of the time interval
of interest and then we want to use the
uh ROM to simulate the remaining half of
the time interval of
Interest so over the um first a half we
find the average denoted with the TAA
and then we get the fluctuation over the
average uh we do this for the four
variables so the two potential vtic and
the two string functions and perform pod
to extract the first R modes again we
are really forcing that our number to be
small to prioritize computational
efficiency and uh then what the does is
that over the entire time interval so we
want to see how well we approximate the
flow for the time interval that was used
for training and then as I said uh for
uh the same amount of time that was not
seen though in the training phase and uh
so for the uh entire time interval we
take the average computed over the
training interval and we are summing the
um ROM approximation for the
fluctuation with the uh basis function
extracted from pod and coefficients that
we have to
learn the way we learn the coefficients
is by using uh a long shortterm memory
Network these are uh recurrent neural
networks that have layers made of cells
and um here is uh what a cell looks like
that the we are using CN to represent
the cell State and uh that is the that
serves as the long-term memory of the
network in each cell we have a forget
gate which decides what information to
discard from the cell State we have an
input gate so that is FN the forget gate
we have an input gate I in that
determines which information to add to
the cell State and uh finally we have an
output gate uh that controls the
information to be passed to the next
cell based on the cell State and the
input uh all the hyperparameters that we
have used are specified in this uh PR
print uh that uh is available on archive
uh what we found that uh the network is
most sensitive to is the um hyper
parameter called look back window uh
which is how many uh time steps you use
uh to determine how um how the solution
over how many time steps you Ed to
determine the uh model coefficients of
the next
time so let me show you uh how this um
data driven ROM that uses p
to find a reduced basis and lstm to
learn the model coefficients for this
double Jer test that I was mentioning
earlier we have a special domain which
is 01 * -11 so rectangular domain
remember we are in uh we are using
non-dimensional variables and we are
interested over the Dynamics for 100
time units
uh the rosby number and the rainolds
number are the same that I mentioned
earlier and now you see also fruit
number the friction coefficient with the
bottom of the ocean and the the ratio of
the depth between the two layers so here
we're saying the two layer um are have
the same depth which is half of the uh
ocean entire ocean depth we use a a mesh
size that resolves the monk scale for
the given parameters and then we have a
Time step which is of the order of 10 to
the
5th um as I said the uh full order
simulation for this problem takes over
eight
days West are uh the ROM that we are
proposing uh we can uh of course reduce
that by a lot and uh let me tell you how
what we did here we considered uh 401
snapshots for each of the four variables
over a time interval 10 to 50 and we are
uh uh requesting only uh 10 basis
functions for the reduced basis so we're
taking the first 10 pod modes and we are
setting now the look back window to 10
we uh perform several um uh we we um use
several values of the look B when and
then found that this was the um the one
that was giv the most accurate
results the uh prediction time interval
is from 50 to 100 time units and the
computational time that it takes the ROM
to uh to simulate these remaining 50
time units is less than 1 second so here
you see the time average Fields average
over the entire uh time uh interval of
Interest so 0 to 100 uh reconstruct from
the solution reconstructed with the ROM
again using 10 pod modes and look back
window equal to 10 um on the First
Column you see the average potential
vorticity in top layer and bottom layer
and on the left column you see the uh
average stream function top layer bottom
layer uh in each sub panel you have the
uh full order method on the left and the
uh
ROM uh the the solution computed by the
ROM on the right now let me start with
the uh potential vorticity you see that
the solution is not very accurate at the
interface it gets spoiled but away from
the interface uh it can uh correctly
capture the average and this is true
both for the top layer and the bottom
layer uh the uh stream functions is
better reconstructed by the the the by
the ROM here again the time average in
fact you see that we can uh well
reproduce the shape of the gers as well
as the magnitude of the average stream
function both for the top layer and the
bottom
layer what I am reporting on the slide
is also the root mean square error for
all the
cases um so so why we have a better
approximation for the uh stream function
than for the uh potential vorticity this
is due to the fact that with 10 basis
function you are retaining about uh 50%
between 50 and 60% of the igen value
energy for the stream function the
stream function has some a somewhat
faster IG value DEC than the potential
vorticity while for the potential
vorticity uh with 10 basis function
you're only retaining 10% of the I value
energy so uh it's we can improve these
results by simply increasing the number
of the uh basis functions 10 is somewhat
drastic and again was to so that the
computational savings were
prioritized so that this was a um a
comparison in terms of time average but
we also checked uh time dependent
quantities and what I'm showing you here
is a comparison of the evolution of the
model
coefficients uh you have here the first
and the third model coefficient for the
uh potential vorticity in the top layer
and same first and third model
coefficient for the um potential
verticity in the bottom layer
with uh the blue line is true in the
sense that the evolution of the
coefficients for the uh full order
Solutions in Orange you have the
Reconstruction so the uh ROM
reconstructing the time window the
solution over the time window that was
used for the training and in green the
um reconstruction of the solution for
the time window that was not used for
the training and considering that for
for the potential verticity we're
retaining only 10 to 20% of the I value
energy this is um a rather a
surprisingly good result and let me
mention that the uh the as as you can
see here there was no instability um
that arised in the uh solution with the
ROM which again is surprising given the
fact that we are discarding modes that
are important into the Dynamics of the
problem now in uh the remaining time
that I have which is uh how much 15
minutes maybe what have Okay I uh want
to go back to this uh slide over here
where um I was showing that if you
wanted to do a full order simulation for
the entire uh time interval of interest
that takes over 8 days which means that
if you're
uh generating data over half of the uh
time interval to be able to train the
data driven ROM you're still stuck with
a 4-day
simulation so the work that I'm uh
talking about next is so that we can
reduce this time here and drastically
reduce it now for us to be able to do
that we chose not to go down a data
driven path but a path that is physics
driven so as I mentioned um earlier this
is a problem that is convection
dominated and uh as you know in a uh
turbulent flow you have um turbulent
structur so addes that spin in
increasingly larger uh range of scales
as the Ral number increases uh and um if
uh you want to have a uh Sol a computed
solution that is physical you need to be
able to either resolve all of those
scales or account for the scales that
are not resolved if you resolve all the
scales so if you can afford a mesh that
is fine enough to cap to capture all the
vertices in your problem from vertices
that are as larg as the domain
comparable in size with the size of the
domain down to the smallest vertices
that have the called mot of scale that
is that is a DNS of course in a problem
like ocean modeling that is out of
question you're not able to do that and
uh and so um you need to use one of the
Alternatives that are two direct
numerical simulation that have been
developed over the uh over the
years the uh two approaches that have
become more widespread in uh in science
and Industry are Lees so larg simulation
and run rolds average nav stocks
equations in the case of Lees you choose
to just take a mesh that is coarser than
you should take it uh to be and resolve
part of the vortices in your flow and
then you choose to model the effect of
the uh edies that are not uh resolved
directly and uh since uh what happens at
the smaller uh at the smaller sces is
dissipation of energy what this is doing
is uh bringing in terms into your
problem that dissipate the energy of the
system the other approach is Rens where
you resolve the flow average and model
everything else we uh chose to work with
Lees and uh in particular we uh focused
on an approach that adds an extra set of
equations to the problem in our case the
two layer qg with the extra problem
being a differential low pass
filter that is intended to smooth out uh
numerical
oscillations so let me tell you how this
uh method works this uh alas method
works for a generic problem if I show it
how it works for the two layer qg it's
just too messy so let me let me just
talk about it in
general let's consider a uh generic
fluid model here uh and let youu be the
variable m is just contains all the
operators that are in your fluid model
now take the model and discretize it in
time for example with backward Oiler
again this is a choice for uh uh
Simplicity one can use different uh time
discretization schemes so uh we have now
the problem discrete in time now if we
further apply space discretization to
the time discrete problem and choose to
use a mesh that has a mesh size much
larger than the colog of scale the
solution that we get out of our solver
uh typically features non-physical
oscillations uh if you're lucky that
leads just to a breakdown of your
simulation and so you know that there is
something wrong if you're not lucky the
simulation keeps going you think you
have a physical solution but you do not
so um the uh idea is to attenuate or
remove the oscillations through a
filtering
operation so we propose to use a
three-step
algorithm the first is evolve which
means that you're app you're using the
solver that that you have without the
filter with the difference that you are
not accepting the solution that you get
out of it as the end of Step solution
it's just an intermediate solution that
at step two you filter so you take the
solution that comes out of the evolv
step filter it with a generic spal
filter and get a v bar the filtered
solution uh the third step here is just
a simple relaxation so you take a linear
combination
of the Evolve variable and the filtered
variable with a relaxation parameter
that varies between zero and
one now if you look at the um at the
algorithm like this it might not look
like standard Le modeling to you but you
can easily see the connection between
the Evolve filter relax algorithm and
Lees modeling if you shift the index
from n + 1 to n in steps two and three
and plug them into step one so here you
can write this in terms of U of unu N
and once you have un n you plug it into
uh step one that will have VN and V Barn
that you can get from step two so what
you get through the those three steps is
um so what you're actually solving is
your original problem plus a term that
as you see is explicitly
treated and it is designed to be uh to
to dissipate
energy so when you look at it like this
it looks more like a standard uh Lees
model now if you're looking at this
ratio here of filtering parameter and
time step and you're not liking it
because this blows up as the uh time
step is reduced
nobody is well nothing is really
preventing you from taking the
relaxation parameter to be a multiple of
the time step so that here you get a
parameter that is not depending on the
time step and so what the Evolve filter
relax algorithm gives you is a Time
stepping procedure to solve a problem
that is that contains the terms from
your original problem
plus an extra term that is designed to
dissipate
energy um now let me see if I have time
uh I let me tell you briefly what kind
of uh spatial filter we use at step two
also actually you know maybe uh instead
of doing that let me tell you why it is
advantageous to have a procedure that is
in uh in three steps like this the first
one is that you have a procedure that is
modular so you typically have a solver
for um lower rainold number flow and by
adding two simpler steps you can upgrade
your uh solver so that also higher Ros
number flow can be simulated so
modularity is the First advant Advantage
that you have here that gives you also
ease of implementation and then the
second Advantage is that you have um
flexibility in the choice of the uh
spatial
filter the special the uh particular uh
spatial filter that we use is um
nonlinear it is well established um wri
in here a partial selection of works
that I have used it uh and uh
for this is mostly for the
incompressible um nav equations and the
filter is like this it is the uh inverse
of identity plus calligraphic L which is
minus the Divergence of a an artificial
diffusion times the
gradient so the artificial diffusion is
where the where the nonlinearity comes
into play and it is defined as the
filtering radius so that is the radius
of the domain where you extracting you
are extracting in the information for
the filtering and that is typically
taken of the order of the mesh size
times an indicator function that takes
as input the Evolve variable and the
indicator function is really crucial
here it takes values between zero and
one with the value being close to zero
in the regions of the domain where you
do not need local filtering so where the
solution is in quote smooth enough
and instead the uh value of the
indicator function is closer to one
where we want to filter the uh computed
solution out of the evolved step so
really here the indicator function is a
key player because it is telling you
where in your domain you should add
artificial diffusion and how much uh
artificial diffusion you should be
adding so it's uh again the indicator
function is crucial to the success of
the uh Evol filter relax algorithm there
is a lot of literature on possible
indicator functions and they are mostly
based on the physics of the problem so
they're trying to identify structures in
the flow that are that are coherent that
don't break down and dissipate uh energy
instead uh we decided to work with an
indicator function that is more
mathematics based than physics
based so we Define it like this to
define the indicator function we use the
uh linear helmets filter uh which is
simply the filter that I showed you
earlier where you take the indicator
function to be equal to one everywhere
so it becomes a linear
filter uh this uh the inverse of the
filter is
unbounded and the the convolution the
approximated the convolution operator is
a bounded regular approximation for the
inverse of the filter so we Define the
indicator function using the filter so
we are filtering the uh evolve variable
if the Evolve variable uh has large
oscillations between elements uh the
filter will smooth them out then the
convolution is only an approximation for
the inverse of the filter so if you have
this large oscillations it's not going
to be able to reconstruct the Evolve
velocity and so this difference becomes
different from zero the it gets closer
to zero if the Evolve velocity uh is uh
um smooth so that the filter uh doesn't
do much to it and the approximated the
convolution operator can reconstruct
it um so here uh is a
comparison between the same problem as
before the two two Jer uh uh benchmark
test on and we're looking at the time
average uh uh stream function for the
top layer uh on the first uh column here
you see the solution G given by in
quotes DNS meaning the using the
rainolds number they has only the that
uses the Ed viscosity that remember
forces you to take a rather fine mesh
which is what gives you a large
computational time if you take it the
mesh and make make it um eight time
coarser because you want uh you want the
simulation to be cheaper and just run
your solver for the two layer qu
geostrophic equations you see that what
you get the solution that you get out of
there is just not physical because
you're not uh your system is not
dissipating energy correctly if you add
the nonlinear filter you are you can uh
you obtain a solution that is closer to
the DNS solution in terms of shape of
the gerss and also magnitude of the
solution this is for layer one and this
is the comparison for Layer Two DNS two
layer qg on the co mesh without the
nonlinear filter and with the nonlinear
filter again you see an improvement of
the solution without the filter and with
a mesh that is 8 time corser and the use
of the nonlinear filter you go from
having to wait 8 days for your
simulation to finish to having uh to
wait only a couple of hours sorry uh oh
yes um this is um sorry I didn't notice
that here you have a mesh that it's even
coarser than that that's why you go from
2 hours to 44 minutes and uh though you
know we can argue that this is already
too course to be able to retrieve an
accurate apprach o imation of the
solution from DNS now let me
finish uh What uh we did to be able to
reduce the computational time
considerably is to combine a data driven
ROM and a physics driven large ID
simulation technique um I put here on
the slides the uh papers where uh the
details of the work that I show today
are discussed and uh this is the open
source of solware that is based on open
Pham that we've used for the uh full
order simulations so with that let me
thank you for your
attention yes thanks for the wonderful
talk Anda is a very interesting and
complete on both physics and data drien
method um so I don't see any questions
in the chat room yet but uh as we give
the audience a moment together there
first I jump in questions to King STS so
um probably I will start with first for
question so I'm curious how the external
forcing by the win in the equation yes
yeah it's model is it time dependent or
independent no in this case we we just
uh it's a constant and it's a sign
function mhm yes this is how uh so and
you um I'm telling you what we set it
for the that two
G um
Benchmark MH sorry let me actually get
here uh here right in in for this test
it's simply a uh sign function uh in the
Y variable so that you observe the
formation of the two
gers yes but uh you're right I mean in a
uh in a realistic case so not in the
case of this particular Benchmark this
would be a forcing that depends with
time right yes so this kind of like
independ time independent force is based
on some kind of physics assumption on
the like the stress pattern on of the
wind or something else I would think
that is just some kind of averaging
because so you you see that what you get
with that kind of sign function in the Y
variable is the formation of two gerss
and these G structures right are
observed in oceans
and so I would suspect that you know in
average that would be a reasonable
approximation I see yeah I asking
because I'm thinking whether the P rstm
Rom that you train can be like adapted
to like predictive cases even like not
in the fluid numbers yes I see what
you're saying if you have a the wind
that varies in an unpredictable way
right is that yeah yes we haven't tried
that yes absolutely I see and like a
really a closely related question is
okay considering all these parametric
things like the flid number the r number
so I I also saw that Comm growth M with
DEC is a little slow in the in the so if
you imagur the full parametri case so
would it be very hard to get a um
Dimension reduction in the P
basis um so that is the thing right
because here here we didn't we managed
to have simulation ROM um simulations
that were stable and approximated that
the time average quantities and the time
dependent quantities reasonably well
without having to um account for the
discarding modes right and um so I
suspect that here with the STM and the
fact that you have a dynamics that is
oscillating over this average uh helps
for that um in what you could do right
uh in in the case of uh different
parameters is add to the model some
closure I see right yes in the and this
is not if we go to for example the um
the gallin Run
right in this case uh this is what you
would use if Ral to 10 would be enough
to capture the Dynamics of your system
but if it it is not sufficient like in
the case of the qge uh or the other
convection dominated problem what you
can do is add a term here just like you
do in LS right to model the effect of
those discarded modes I see
okay maybe we have minutes for a quick
question so maybe I can ask one more so
as you mentioned the Lo back window is a
very sensitive parameter in the so per
ask for any if you have any insights on
or experience on deciding the low back
window in the setting of R and I imagine
the L window has to be long enough to
capture the temporal changes and if it's
too long it will be overfitting so
correct ex that's exactly our experience
and I wish I had a better answer for you
than we just did TR trial and error but
I don't we we started from Two and then
we increased it until we saw that it was
not improving the uh approximation
anymore and 10 was that sweet spot after
which we were seeing that overfitting
that you're talking about I see yes do
you see any relation between the optim I
mean the 10 the window of 10 is related
to the number of pod modes or if you
like increase or decrease the no no no
no we've changed also the number of pod
modes and uh that did not seem to affect
the fact that 10 was the best value for
the um for the look back window